i was here earlier i'd have more content
and
actually i want to kind of explain to
bobby right now
why you're here right now oh yeah so
steve
steve came to my house a few nights ago
and we talked
for hours about you
hours it's so uncomfortable i can't even
do it this is an intervention
no it's not an interesting thing it's so
uncomfortable i can't even [ __ ]
believe it
so let me ask you you just told me i'm
so
[ __ ] uncomfortable i can't stand it
but
can you for a little bit because he's
here
[Music]
can you be open to hearing what we have
to say yeah you okay can you be open to
hearing what we have to say
no matter how uncomfortable it makes
yeah go ahead
oh here we go bound number eight they've
been bowing the whole time for respect
oh okay
oh that's you don't have to i don't have
to guess
um i like that bow that's a newbo
all right so oh listen that's my dad
i didn't know okay okay okay oh my gosh
[Laughter]
is this your father's for um
all right okay so you know what you're
uncomfortable i know
you know what i'm going to do what i'm
going to do is i'm going to do this i'm
going to take the
earphones off and you're going to close
your eyes and i'm going
to listen like oh wow oh wow
i want my ears to hear this maybe
[ __ ]
[ __ ] maybe close your eyes mike mike
maybe close your eyes
maybe close your eyes no don't close
your eyes no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no i don't want
to click look at me
because this is sabotage i love it go
ahead you think this is sound i don't
know what it is let's just do it okay
you think this is a no i'm not do you
want me to go or do you want to go do
you go first okay i'll be talking to
this guy
all right okay okay dad when i tell him
how much i love him i think
um can you can you hear me everyone's
good on the mic
you want headphones oh no i'm okay okay
mike now oh okay really
okay um it's not that intense
i i we were just talking and you know
dave is
great because if you know if you have an
idea he pushes the button and then we're
just on to the idea
but basically we were just talking about
you and
how underappreciated you are
and we wanted to come tell you that like
that's what you talked about
yeah what is it okay i'm genuinely
genuine like like we were we were
talking about
because i cuz i know you're doing a bit
sometimes too is like sometimes i list
when i listen to tiger belly
the fun bit that i hear you do is that
uh
nobody respects you or your career
and that's not true that's not true
especially for me yeah because i
massively respect i know you do yeah
i mean i don't know that you but you
know it's it's funny it's like
let me go back in here wait what
happened to the listening part
i just listened to it could make me a
response no i i didn't i didn't get to
say what i
you've been talking for [ __ ] that's
true that's true that's true
i want to hear more i want to oh yeah go
ahead
i i can't yeah give me can i respect
your father
here i got your dad no i got him i'm
gonna hold him
so we start talking about tiger belly we
start talking about you
and um it's just
uh you know we could you know we could
talk about the handcuff stuff this and
that but
the pain i feel of
when i hear you go into like man i went
into this pitch meeting i didn't get the
thing
i used to be on the show called mad tv
it's never said like
it's a show from like 20 30 years ago
and i just
sit there and i go what you heard what
steve just said i and i go i wonder if
bobby knows
what he means to me and then i say that
to steve and he goes
i wonder if bobby knows what he means to
us
and it's like i i have it all i'm fine
oh no i'm thriving but it's like
everything you've ever wanted everything
that's like
like do you know what you mean to me
do you know what you that's why i asked
you are you open to here and you said
you're gonna sit
not the way i thought it was gonna go
you walked into cafe 101 and and you do
the beta
there's a warlock there with nail polish
you do the whole thing and
i never ever in my life thought i would
meet you
and and i never thought i would meet you
again which is why i was like this is my
chance
right and you say all this [ __ ] you
changed my brother's life
this all that you changed my life you
changed my life
and i i i want you to hear it even
though it makes you uncomfortable
like see why you got to do that i don't
know why i did why do you got to do that
i was sneezing
all right that was a sneeze i mean are
you taking in
anything that was yes i am that's why i
closed my eyes where i'm absorbing it
but i get it
i get i can't
hear even i g i get
the the cringe of this thing
but you know we even talked about it i
was like i don't know if i
maybe i should just call him personally
but then you know this is more
yeah intense
[Laughter]
hollywood baby but but truly
bobby you're like not
you're i think you know this but
sometimes it just feels nice to hear it
like you did it when nobody
else could
you did it for us yes
did that feel foolish thank you
don't laugh we we you you did it but but
it's serious but
don't turn it into a joke i'm not don't
turn you did it you did it you did it
i receive it you did it
receive it i've i've absorbed it
inside my body and i'm going to say
something in return and i'm going to be
as
authentic and as real as i can be okay
number one it's the realization that
it really doesn't mean that much at the
end of the day it's like
i have everything that i need okay
honestly i do i have a house i have some
money saved up
i have a beautiful girlfriend i have
friends
my mom's still alive my brother's with
us and he's thriving as well
so that's number one number two is
i really believe that i am owning up to
who i am not just as a human being
but also as an entertainer okay and i
in this last year it's been very
fruitful for me
i'm working all the time and things have
been great
and um anyway i'm going to new york to
do something else you know i mean next
month
you know i got sex in the city right so
i'm doing that
and i'm doing you know and i'm so
for me when i hear you guys say that
right
it's you know um it really means a lot
because obviously i love both of you i
think you both are
incredibly talented and i really do
appreciate it and i almost got really
emotional emotional there you know
and i had i have defense mechanisms and
i you you you're
you're you're doing it i i i let me can
i just finish
cause that's your thing what i don't
want to yell don't
i love you you know when i yell at you
and i go tiger belly could be the
biggest show and
and that's like me that's you're right
that is
that's that is old dave but today i
just accept you like you don't have to
be on sex in the city you don't have to
do
any of that and so i i didn't say that
just for you
well what's just saying that look you're
getting angry again and i'm not getting
angry
i just want you to really understand
what but you know you know what happened
to me on the drive here
i was like i need to download some bobby
so i listened to bad friends your newest
episode
so good and then um the beginning of the
episode you were just recounting how
much work you had and then i almost
turned the car around be like [ __ ] he
doesn't need me to come over here and
say this [ __ ]
and i you didn't need me to i just just
to be clear
yeah this is awkward for me because i
know you don't need this and this wasn't
me
this is not an intervention or us coming
here to be like you feel down on
yourself
for me it's just like we sat there i
haven't talked to you in a while yeah
and so now i get to like tell you
in a time when
and i don't want to shrink you down to
just asian american but like in a time
when asian americans are getting a
spotlight
just on that lane of what you've done
for the community beyond
separate from humanity but what you've
done for that specific community
massive and people don't get it i
and that's kind of what i want to say is
less to you
and more on this program i don't think
people fully realize
what bobby lee did for
asian americans oh this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] at my house
we're having this conversation at my
house and i'm like
i wish i was better friends with bobby
so i could call him right now and he
would pick up the phone and we could
tell him on person
and i said you know what i would what
steve's telling to me is like making me
emotional
and so i'm like i want to tell this to
bobby but he's never going to pick up my
call
i should just go on tiger belly and tell
him
and so here i am now and you're getting
and you're getting
you're getting and and so we start the
show and he goes
oh without dvd i say there's no tiger
belly there's no
[ __ ] us without you there's no us
without you that's true that's true i'm
a bruce lee
there's nothing there's a void there's
nothing
there's nothing how about this you know
and then there's bobby lee on mad tv and
you're like
oh there's hope yeah there's a light at
the end of the tunnel what you
meant to me a young me what you meant to
a young steve yeah
yeah you know what's great i want you to
hear that 100
100 i hear that and i remember
an episode of tiger belly where you tell
the story about you guys were at a
korean barbecue
and you were talking about how like you
are you self-anointed yourself as a
korean something
parks barbecue yeah at parks and then
you [ __ ] ate it and
that's because it's the shittiest raw
deal
to have to anoint yourself in your own
mind to
the worth that you inhabit
and that's kind of the function that i'm
trying to
serve here with dave is like let me just
give it to you like you got it like you
did it
and you did it for us you [ __ ] did it
you did it for us
um i don't get asked to um do the um
yeah
psas we don't want you
i you know i get together with steve ali
wong dave chang and we go
we don't want this guy here can i just
tell you something
i care about it yeah and i think i have
a voice and i want to say you know
say hey man stop the asian violence but
you know what though what i'm saying is
your existence is more powerful than you
realize
to uh like in that you just doing this
[ __ ] show is more stop asian hate
than anything yes
like you just being here and being your
thriving funny [ __ ] self is
like you don't what were you gonna say
don't hurt me
don't hit me yeah you like it when
people hit you
you're really offended but that's but
your existence is the protest
and your existence has been the protest
since the beginning of your career
and that's kind of the validation that
we're trying to put out there
for you again not that you need it but
just
for the knowledge it's just like sitting
here it's like bruce lee that's not me
there's this asian waiter that's not me
and then and then there's this guy
this guy with the he comes out and i go
okay
i got really i got emotional and you
know
the first the third day i was on mad tv
a producer called me into his office and
he said
sit down i sat down he goes when you
auditioned i didn't want you on the show
i don't
i don't think that you're talented i
don't think that you're right for the
show
he's a producer on the show and i know
really and he goes
yeah it's just like the owner of the
show really likes you and a couple of
other guys but like i just
you know so basically he was saying like
me and my
my writing staff that the people that i
probably going to write you things you
know we said don't
take it personally we just you know and
i remember turning around
walking out of that room just in like
in the verge of tears right going
oh this is even when i get something
yeah it's there's another
hurdle and there's another wall i have
to climb yeah and this
that one was one that was like so high
up right because i had to change
his mind and when you don't have the
opportunity on the show
right you don't get a lot of screen time
and parts written
how are you going to hit the ball right
so it's like it was a
it was you know it was tough
you know and i stayed on there i just
just showed up
you know i showed up and it was hard i
think you didn't just show up though
you took several years
of [ __ ] beatings
and yet you thrived like they put
weights on you
and you still thrived and
you're out here now thriving independent
of that
yeah and i wonder like
you know you could take the weights off
too
what a concept wow
wow and that's not an intervention point
that's for me like
as someone that launched off of your
trailblazing and your shoulders i can
say there's a point at which i was like
oh cool i could take this off i put this
i kept this on
and it became a thing i justified and
now i could take this [ __ ] off
and then you're just like [ __ ] i'm good
like i can do it
okay i just uh you know you know i don't
know what this is
but um what do you mean this guy comes
to my house no i know i know what it is
no i'm just saying i i know what it is
it's just
um i wasn't expecting this and um
i you know i appreciate what you guys
just did
and this is the first time in my life
where i
agree with you in the sense that like
yeah it was hard and i did do it and i
and they didn't want
a korean guy on the show they were like
we want to we need a white guy because
you know and then they they tested me
and taryn killum
and they're like we want the white guy
but we'll bring the asian guy just as an
experiment right
my point is is that everything was kind
of difficult
and um and i just i always knew like
when i'm at a i'll be honest with you
when i'm at a comedy club
and i'm stacked up against all these
white and black guys and this and that i
know
that i can carry my way and i know that
i will be
as funny or funnier than all of them
right
i believe that you are i know i believe
that
you know i've seen it i've i've i've
done
it and i mean i've seen it so all those
it's hard to say because it's like how
do you toot your own horn yeah yeah
it's just a difficult thing to do you
know and um
i um i hear you guys and i really really
that means a lot to me and i really
appreciate it
you know i think that this was a um we
appreciate your hard work yeah
it's really good we see you yeah are you
getting emotional
i am because i think that i don't know
just like
we've been together a decade and when i
met him he was so
broken and he was so down on himself and
he was just so like lost and he was
still like
looking at these gatekeepers of
hollywood thinking like
hand me something have i not done enough
and i've just always been like
on the sidelines like desperately trying
to tell him like
he's worthy but i'm a nobody i was just
a nurse you know and i'm just somebody
that loves him
so they hear it from you guys you know
like
established people like it means a lot
to me because i feel like that
reverberates more in him
in his body than it would coming from
you know somebody like me who just loves
him for whatever chaos comes
whatever form shape that he comes in
right
and so that means a lot to me
hearing that your words and your
acceptance
of the fullness of bobby as he is
is the most powerful thing that he can
have
like straight up my wife is
like she takes me to she sees me when
i'm taking shits
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah and
she's still here yeah
so like [ __ ] everyone else
i've seen it it's powerful [ __ ] it's
really hard
yeah man but i i all that to say like i
believe
i'm not here to tell you anything like
you already know i'm just here to tell
that's why i think this public forum is
cool because it's like
cool every [ __ ] that didn't
realize that bobby lee like
set [ __ ] up for people and
us and took man i mean
i know how hard it was and still how
hard it is
for me to navigate this industry
and you did it when nobody was there
nobody
and we do the the you know whatever it
turned into a bit we're doing the
bow joking thing that's not a joke
that's not a joke
yeah i know it's not uh now i know it's
not
um listen you know i don't want to cry
anymore
why not because it felt good
it felt good it was a release i felt
good about it and i released
um you know i um people need to pay
respect to you yeah
i i know and we did that
we did that and i i honestly
from the bottom of my [ __ ] heart
thank you too for doing that
i've never that i never dreamt that
people like you guys like
guys i really respect i really do like
in terms of
like i go this is these guys are younger
and i can't even believe that you know
sometimes you know
i can't believe that certain people like
me whatever it feels good you know so
it's like
i want to say thank you for doing that
it's you know
so much respect there and i believe you
and i um i'm never gonna forget it
i'm never gonna forget it oh shout out
to tia carrera that was another one i
really
oh yeah i love her yo you're not the
only one
you're not the only one but you know
what yeah the distinction
that i make that you did
was you didn't try to fit
within the prism of what asian america
was supposed to be
yeah at that time and you frequently
continuously
broke it even when the community itself
didn't want you to break it like that
but that's a lot
that's [ __ ] balls and it's a lot of
work so much work
that's why when he says you could put
the weights down now yeah yeah it's like
when kalila shares and like
just hearing her makes me emotional like
that because it's like that's
that's your woman man she loves you and
um
it's it's like uh does it make more
sense now
because we've been battling before
before the postmates guy got here
[Laughter]
no it's like i i i love you so much
that when i feel the way that kalila
must feel all the time being
it does make me angry because i'm like i
wish you could see
yourself the way i see you and like this
[ __ ] guy shows up to my house
and we're just doing a bobby lee fest
i'm like let's tell him yeah
let's just tell him like why are we
saying it to each other he should hear
this [ __ ]